becoming a Jesuit is kind of a long
process you start as a Jesuit novice
which is two years in a place called the
novitiate and you do a combination of
prayer and working with the poor in the
middle of all that two years you do a 30
day silent retreat based on what are
known as the Spiritual Exercises of st.
Ignatius Loyola which is kind of an
imaginative placing yourself in the
gospel scenes and sort of accompanying
Jesus through the gospel scenes
imaginatively
after the novitiate you take what are
called your simple vows of poverty
chastity and obedience after that you do
what's called first studies which is a
combination of philosophy and theology
and then following that you do three
years of full-time work which is called
in the Jesuits Regency most Jesuits like
to teach they'll teach in a high school
somewhere I worked overseas at a in the
Jesuit Refugee service helping refugees
in East Africa start small businesses
for themselves so after that three years
is done you go to theology studies and
you three or four years of theology
studies and if you're a priest you get
ordained at the end there's Jesuit
brothers as well on people who are
Jesuits but are not called to the
priesthood and then after ordination you
work full-time for a couple of years I'm
working in a Catholic magazine and
finally at the end of probably five or
six years after that you take what are
called your final vows so the whole
process is pretty long it took me
21 years to become a Jesuit which I
think was a little too long for my taste
but that's that's pretty average it
takes about 20 years to to become a full
fledged Jesuit I like to say it's um
it's like being a made man in the Mafia
or getting tenure at a university or
becoming a partner you know you've been
in for a while but but you've you're
finally finally fully accepted so it's a
pretty long process
poverty is one of the three vowels that
we take we take about poverty chastity
and obedience and you know initially st.
ignatius loyola when he had his
conversion experience he was injured in
a battle and was taken home to
recuperate and started to think about
doing something else with his life he
became very ascetical and gave up
everything and really lived like a
hermit lived in a cave let his
fingernails grow long has his hair grow
long and ultimately he realized that
this wasn't really doing him much good
and he needed to moderate some of this
he ended up going back to school to
learn and so he thought well Jesuits
should be free of material possessions
but they don't have to live you know
like they're Hermits like they're living
in a cave and eating twigs and things
like that it's not a it's not a complete
poverty so Jesuit poverty is really
about freedom it's about the freedom of
not owning things it's about the freedom
of living simply and it's also about the
freedom to not let anything any
possessions come in between you and God
at the same time it's supposed to help
us identify with the poor where we do a
lot of work with the poor and we're
supposed to try to live as close as
possible to what's in Ignatius calls a
family of slender means you know people
who don't have a lot and also it's
supposed to model Christ I mean Jesus
when he lived on the earth was living
very simply as a very simple man and so
those are the three things it frees us
up for service it makes makes it so we
don't have a lot of possessions to kind
of like tie us down it helps us identify
with the poor and it's an imitation of
Christ it's really trying to follow
Christ more closely
yeah chastity is the most difficult
thing to explain about religious life I
mean most people think it's crazy or
unhealthy or a natural you know after
the sex abuse crisis people think that
the sex abuse crisis came from chastity
or from celibacy but it's really is
actually a different way to love it's
certainly not for everybody
I mean clearly you know most people are
called to romantic love and married
lives and having children but for some
of us it works and and really what it is
it's loving many people freely and
deeply you're not attached to just one
person you don't have an exclusive
relationship so you're free to love many
people which is not to say the people
who are married or are in a romantic
relationship can't love many people it's
just to say that this is what works best
for people in religious orders and I
find it very freeing I find people can
be freer with me in a sense you know
when I become close friends with
somebody they're not wondering is he
becoming friends because of sex you know
does he have an ulterior motive
something like that men and women can
feel comfortable with you and really in
a practical level it makes you a lot
more mobile you're not in a sense
worried about what your wife or husband
is going to be thinking about you're
moving or taking a new job so it can be
very freeing but it really freaks people
out I mean chastity really you know in a
culture that values sex you know and
rightly so much it really disturbs
people but I think you know for those
people who are called to it it can work
very well if you live it in a healthy
way meaning if you have friends and have
healthy work and a healthy prayer life
so I'm all for it but it's not for
everybody